Hey youtubers, it’s Charlie welcome to my
very first South Park Stick of Truth video.
Anytime I do gameplay videos I’ll try to
include as much commentary on the show as
is relevant to the action.
The are a lot of things about the game that
I’ve already noticed that make it the best
licensed game I’ve ever seen and even after
you finish the game there’s still the fun
of going back and looking for a the little
touches they added in the development process
to make it feel like an interactive episode
rather than just being a sweet RPG.
Before I get started we need to crown some
winners in my steam giveaway.
Congratulations to Swinnythe1 and furry fear,
you guys win two $20 gift cards.
I’ll be messaging you guys on your channel
for details.
So quick show of hands.
Down in the comments let me know if you’ve
bought the game and which class you’ve rolled.
Your first time through.
If you blew through it on release day and
are replaying on other classes you deserve
a high five.
The best games are always worth playing more
than once.
Back when I was in college I was a swimmer,
so during the summers I still had to train
with my team two or three times a day michael
phelps style.
In order to keep from going crazy in between
practices I would play all of the classic
Final Fantasy games on my old playstation.
I had to go to a vintage store to find the
games, but when I wasn’t passed out I would
probably spend about 80 or 90 hours per game.
That’s also how I read Harry Potter.
For a couple of summers it was the best vacation
ever.
Final Fantasy is still my favorite RPG series,
but when World of Warcraft was released I
really drank the kool aide and spent most
of my time on it up till Wrath of Litch King.
Then I did that thing where after you play
an MMO waaay to much and take a break for
a year or two then come back.
I’m not playing it right now, just because
I’m spending all my time making youtube
videos.
Which is probably the best social game ever
created.
Yes that’s right, I totally just called
youtube a social game.
So let’s dive into stick of truth.
For anyone that’s wondering my rig at home
is a custom core i5 with a 760 gtx and a korean
1440 monitor.
I’m thinking about going back to two 24”
monitors but we’ll see.
Sometimes having the giant monitor makes it
harder to multitask.
For this first intro vid I’ll just say a
little bit about aspects of the game that
I find really interesting.
And if anyone has an opinion on it, I turned
subtitles on in the game for my let’s play
videos just for anyone that really likes subtitles.
If you guys hate them
just
let me know and I’ll turn them off.